you look absolute mess Daniel eighth
floor color good never have that's too
big
you should rip it in this shot used to
feel like so I could rip hello and
welcome to my god
hello down over the story for you today
in this here video I was at my crafting
table just the other day oh yeah and I
had an iron ingot and also a piece of
Flint that I found in some gravel remind
way yeah mining actually a little bit of
mining yeah and I put them together I'm
a crafting table and I came up with a
flint and steel Gino I figured we would
film a flint and steel sparking it up
super close up in slow motion Jesus
actually said the hole through it I've
done some serious damage there I think
sorry sorry bad it's not gonna come out
the frames like here and the folks is
like that so try not to move that too
much okay no pressure
alright alright let me know when you go
good luck mate looks good
yes good okay
dammit come on
Oh yup - right this doesn't work
anything like it does in Minecraft I
can't get this wood block to light ah -
look this doesn't do it oh whoa
well I've learned a lot today
yeah so if you're a very exploring with
your flint and steel
just grab the nearest kind of petrol and
here you go you've got fire yeah you
really stepped it up a notch that is
awful
I didn't just do I did that feel
I have to mention this cuz hairdo a
hairdo he forgot the battery for the for
the camera so today we're actually
filming our intros on the iPhone that is
state of the art with a sat-nav holder
on the window this is a perfect tech I
think yeah yeah that's a good effort
improvisation